namaste Elias oh hi there Prakash cushla
gray Oh
odka didn't catch a lie what I'm sorry
what I mean is you seem happy
how's the day going for you I'm doing
fine but Prakash how many languages do
you speak
oh I speak Hindi Konkani my mother
tongue Kannada and a couple more well
that's impressive
you know our customers have users that
speak many languages and Google has
tools to help translate texts but how do
we help customers with industry specific
jargon where technical material that
needs to be translated to a different
language
you mean like sir were in a restaurant
should be translated differently from
server in a data center exactly well
Elias Google Cloud has created just the
thing for this it's called Auto ml
translate it is a way for our customers
to bring their business specific
translation examples and easily train a
custom machine learning model to
understand their domain let me show you
how it's done let's do it
this is the automatic translation user
interface and you're looking at some of
the custom models that are already
trained now let's look at some data sets
that are already in place these are used
to train up the custom models let's
create a new data set first we'll give
it a name then we'll select the source
and target languages English and
Japanese in this case the translation
examples can be supplied in two formats
TSV and TM X files and you can manually
break this up into training testing and
validation datasets or you can let the
system do it automatically
you can upload the files from your drive
or drop them on Google Cloud storage for
this demo I'll pick a file on my drive
clicking on create dataset starts the
import process and this can take a
little while depending upon the size of
the data set for this demo I already
have a data set imported so let's click
through on it on the first screen you'll
see some sample sentences drawn from
this data set on the training tab
there's additional information about
this data set and you can launch the
training by clicking on start training
you can pick the base model from Google
and train up your custom model or you
can continue training a previously
created custom model as well and under
the covers the system automatically
deploys the necessary resources and
handles the training now this can take a
few hours so I have pre trained a model
already for use in this demo so let's go
access that model again when you go to
the train tab you will see some metrics
for this custom model the system
automatically generates a blue score for
the custom model and if the blue score
is higher than the base model it means
that translate
done using this model will be closer to
your reference data side now this data
set has relatively fewer sentence pairs
so these numbers are not typical in your
case with larger data sets you will see
much better blue scores you can of
course continue to train this model and
either create a new version or continue
to train this up until you get the
quality that you're looking for now
once you have the quality that you need
you can go to the predict area and in
this case the system will show you
samples for invoking the custom model we
arrest API or Python code snippets and
on this screen you can quickly run some
translation examples and compare the
results from your custom model with the
base model from Google so this is how we
cloud is making machine learning easily
accessible to everyone by addressing the
two major challenges that slow down
machine learning projects one a need for
deep data science skills and two a need
to manage and deploy your own compute
resources this is really great Prakash
thank you if you really liked this video
please go ahead and share comment and
subscribe and also if you're working on
any cool projects and we like to get in
contact with us please click on the link
in the description thanks for watching
[Music]